[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 1 de julio de 1997 tras 155 años de
soberanía británica hong kong volvió a
formar parte de china
lo hizo como una región administrativa
especial bajo el modelo un país dos
sistemas un modelo amigos que tenía como
objetivo garantizar que hong kong
siguiese siendo hong kong la ciudad más
libre de todo el continente asiático es
decir gracias a esta particular
configuración política
hong kong tiene sus propias leyes su
propia justicia su propio policía su
moneda e incluso la política de aduanas
e inmigración es diferente a la del
resto de china vamos que de facto en el
día a día funciona casi como un país
independiente y seguirá siendo así hasta
por lo menos el año 2047 tal vez por
ello desde que hong kong pasó a manos
chinas las cosas a la ciudad no le han
ido del todo mal
durante este tiempo la economía de hong
kong ha crecido de media un 33 % anual
más de un millón de personas procedentes
de la china continental se han
trasladado a este territorio en busca de
fortuna y la ciudad sigue siendo un
oasis de libertad
[Música]
eso sí la influencia y la intromisión
del gobierno chino en la política local
ha crecido mucho en los últimos años
aquí en visual político ya os hemos
hablado de todo esto por ejemplo en
pasados vídeos hemos hablado ya sobre la
revolución de los paraguas o sobre la
creciente injerencia de pekín en la
política local pues bien amigos en este
vídeo vamos a comentar otra de las
características más destacadas de este
lugar sabíais que hong kong es la ciudad
con las casas más caras y más pequeñas
del mundo atentos
[Música]
un mercado por las nubes
con 7 millones y medio de habitantes y
más de 1200 rascacielos las casas en
hong kong son terriblemente caras bueno
las casas los garajes las oficinas todo
lo que tenga que ver con el sector
inmobiliario es carísimo tanto que
podemos encontrar noticias como esta
bendita en hong kong por seiscientos mil
euros
la plaza de garaje más cara del mundo de
hecho amigos si tuvierais un millón de
dólares de dólares estadounidenses y
quisierais compraros digamos un
apartamento en una de las zonas buenas
de hong kong
apenas podríais comprar los atentos 22
metros cuadrados por un millón de
dólares tal cual como lo escucháis es
una cifra que asusta
hong kong es considerada como la segunda
ciudad de todo el mundo donde las
viviendas premium son más caras tan sólo
por detrás de mónaco el fundador de
alibaba jack ma compra en hong kong la
segunda casa más cara del mundo por
metro cuadrado ha pagado 175 millones de
euros por una casa de 920 metros
cuadrados pero claro si tenemos en
cuenta que
hong kong vive todo tipo de gente y
excepto amos el caso tan particular de
mónaco hong kong es con diferencia la
ciudad con las casas más caras de todo
el planeta
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea desde 2003
el precio de la vivienda ha crecido un
450 por ciento y hoy en esta ciudad el
precio medio del metro cuadrado supera
los 16 mil dólares norteamericanos si
esto quiere decir que si os queréis
comprar una casa normal y está nada de
lujos de 90 metros cuadrados en una zona
normal vais a tener que pagar ojo por lo
menos un millón y medio de dólares de
eeuu pedazo de hipoteca mira hace es muy
habitual para comparar qué ciudades son
más o menos accesibles utilizar los años
de salarios medios antes de pagar
impuestos que necesitamos para comprar
la vivienda media que se vende pues bien
atentos según los últimos datos
publicados para comprar una casa en hong
kong necesitaremos algo más de 18 años
de salarios íntegros por comparar en
ciudades como tokio o singapur se
necesitan menos de 5 años de salarios
es decir lo de hong kong es una locura y
no sólo eso veréis como las casas son
tan caras y tan inaccesibles para los
propios ciudadanos de hong kong pues
éstos han tenido que ir comprando cada
vez casas más pequeñas sabéis qué
superficie tiene una casa media en hong
kong venga mojar os 100 metros cuadrados
80 60 lleva 42 metros cuadrados os
imaginais viviendo en una casa de 42
metros cuadrados pues atentos a la
última moda
hong kong es tan caro que los
arquitectos están construyendo casas
tubería de 10 metros cuadrados hechos
con tuberías de hormigón pero vale puede
que alguno de vosotros esté pensando
guau a enrique es muy poco pero seguro
que es porque muchas personas viven en
diminutos apartamentos que alteran las
estadísticas verdad pues amigos nada de
eso
de media viven casi tres personas en un
apartamento de 42 metros cuadrados
menuda locura y ojo no son sólo las
casas ocurre exactamente lo mismo con
las oficinas
vendida una torre de 346 metros en hong
kong por cuatro mil 419 millones de
euros récord mundial pero claro dicho
todo esto hay una pregunta que seguro
que os estáis haciendo por qué diantres
son tan caras las casas en hong kong
pues atentos
[Música]
el mito de la falta de tierra espacios
masificados rascacielos por todas partes
pisos pequeños que digo pequeños
diminutos y carísimos aparentemente así
es como todos podríamos describir a hong
kong nos parece al fin y al cabo estamos
hablando de uno de los lugares con mayor
densidad de población de todo el mundo y
viendo lo que hemos visto sobre los
precios y los tamaños de la vivienda
blanco y en botella mucha gente y poco
espacio parece la combinación perfecta
para que los precios sean tan altos
verdad puedes esperar un momento amigos
porque decir esto no es contar toda la
verdad
lo cierto es que menos del 25 por ciento
menos de una cuarta parte del territorio
de hong kong está urbanizado y apenas el
7 por ciento de todo el territorio está
ocupado por viviendas urbanas fuera de
las zonas más masificadas podemos
encontrar campos selva aldeas antiguas
campos de golf y muchas muchísimas
viviendas unifamiliares
un momento pero como es esto posible
pues veréis durante años hong kong ha
sido considerada por el índice de
libertad económica como la economía más
libre de todo el planeta es decir
hablamos del lugar con impuestos bajos
comercio libre seguridad jurídica y una
intervención del gobierno muy pequeña
vamos lo que viene siendo una ciudad muy
capitalista por algo es el tercer mayor
centro financiero del mundo otras
londres y nueva york por cierto como
curiosidad la ley básica la constitución
de hong kong limita que el gobierno
pueda gastar más de lo que ingresa esto
ha hecho que el gobierno suele cerrar
todos los años con superávit
es decir gastando menos de lo que
ingresa superávits que ha ido acumulando
para lograr tener unos ahorros ojo de
más de 220 mil millones de dólares si
aquí todo eso de la deuda pública no
hace muchas gracias pero sigamos el caso
es que a pesar de tanta libertad y tanta
apuesta por el capitalismo lo cierto es
que hay un sector muy pero que muy
intervenido por el gobierno
sabéis cuál es pues precisamente el
sector inmobiliario veréis en hong kong
prácticamente toda la tierra es
propiedad del gobierno
[Música]
las autoridades públicas controlan
cuánta tierra y cuándo se pone en el
mercado para poder construir por
supuesto el departamento de vivienda
planificación y tierra también decide
qué es lo que se va a poder construir
generalmente la concesión de tierra se
realiza mediante subastas cuando se
trata de viviendas privadas oficinas o
usos comerciales o directamente mediante
acuerdos con promotores cuando se va a
construir vivienda pública con
alquileres más económicos que es donde
vive una gran parte de la población
[Música]
por cierto lo normal incluso en las
subastas es que la propiedad siga siendo
del gobierno lo que se conceden son
derechos de uso por equis años pues bien
que las casas sean tan caras en hong
kong tiene mucho que ver con la escasez
pero no con la escasez geográfica sino
con una definida por el gobierno
[Música]
tal cual como lo escucháis terreno hay
más que de sobra para desarrollar nuevas
áreas residenciales y de oficinas y
además siempre está la opción de ganar
terreno en el mar si no es nada extraño
una cuarta parte de todas las áreas
edificadas hoy en hong kong se asientan
sobre terrenos que fueron ganados al mar
pero todo absolutamente todo tiene que
ser decidido por el gobierno la escasez
de tierra es un mito hay más de 200
hectáreas de terreno disponibles para
construir en las zonas urbanas la
escasez de viviendas es real pero eso se
debe a la manipulación deliberada del
mercado por el gobierno john wright pues
bien en las últimas décadas como hemos
dicho antes la población de hong kong ha
crecido bastante porque han llegado
muchas personas de china además el
tamaño de la familia se ha reducido y
muchos inversores chinos quieren
invertir en esta ciudad conocida por su
seguridad jurídica para poner su
patrimonio a salvo todo esto ha hecho
que la demanda se dispare algo que no ha
ocurrido con la oferta porque pues
porque el gobierno no ha querido
los precios de las casas crecerán aún
más debido al escaso suministro
tomás la jefe de valoración y
consultoría de knight frank pero qué
interés tiene el gobierno en restringir
la oferta y hacer crecer los precios
pues hay al menos dos motivos el primero
es que las subastas son todo un negocio
para las arcas públicas fijaos en 2017
por ejemplo 1 de cada 5 dólares en
ingresos públicos procedieron de la
venta de suelo hablamos de más de 15 mil
millones de dólares el segundo motivo y
mucho más siniestro es que hay sospechas
de relaciones no muy limpias corrupción
entre las autoridades y los grandes
promotores veréis el sector inmobiliario
en hong kong está muy concentrado en
pocas manos manos que por supuesto son
multimillonarios
y
y digamos que estos grandes empresarios
que dependen del gobierno prefieren
mantener por las nubes los precios y
evitar la competencia algo que sucede
cuando el gobierno saca el mercado poco
suelo y además incrementa la burocracia
para cualquier nuevo proyecto claro así
las pequeñas y medianas empresas no
pueden entrar y las extranjeras tampoco
se atreven porque parten en clara
desventaja por supuesto amigos todo esto
tiene consecuencias atentos
[Música]
las consecuencias
el disparatado precio de las viviendas
ha hecho que a pesar de haber mucho
empleo y salarios altos muchas personas
en esta ciudad vivan en condiciones
difíciles como es para una familia tener
que convivir en 40 metros cuadrados
pagando hipotecas desorbitadas además
este sistema ha hecho que muchas
personas especialmente los más jóvenes
sean dependientes del gobierno
dependientes de los alquileres en
viviendas públicas que por supuesto
también son casas muy pequeñas pensadas
por cierto que en hong kong además no
cabe la posibilidad de irse a vivir al
extrarradio oa zonas más alejadas porque
eso supondría cruzar a la china
continental y perder todas las
libertades que las personas tienen en
esta ciudad
y por si fuera poco el alto precio de
las oficinas y naves empresariales ha
hecho que muchas empresas y muchas
inversiones acaben en otras ciudades del
delta del río de las perlas como
shenzhen lo que plantea problemas de
futuro
pero de todo esto hablaremos otro día en
fin amigos así están las cosas en esta
ciudad que hasta ahora ha sido uno de
los faros más destacados de prosperidad
y libertad en toda asia el futuro nos
dirá qué ocurre y sabéis que en visual
política estaremos muy atentos pero
ahora turno para ti crees que las
autoridades de hong kong deben promover
el crecimiento de la ciudad
incrementando la oferta inmobiliaria
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo de la
like y no olvides suscribirte al canal
si aún no lo has hecho ahora sí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]